Three,
two,
one
cool thing going on here.
Now we'll circle,
oh jeff,
merry Christmas.
What's up Joe?
Youtube not been the easiest week in my
life or my career is last week,
but hanging in there to make this a
standalone so that people don't have to
go figuring this out on their own.
And I'm sure many,
many fans are tuning in already.
Know that.
The gist of the details,
let's lay this out from the beginning.
John Jones.
Initial failed test.
Yeah.
So that was July of 2017 he tested
positive for approximately 20,
anywhere from 20 to 60 Pika grams of a
longterm metabolite known as the m three
metabolite of a substance called to
hydro chloral methyl testosterone,
Dh cmt,
also known as oral to rentable.
And this was over a year ago.
Um,
what was determined to be the source of
this stuff,
never determined what the source was.
So John went through a full arbitration
hearing,
um,
was never able to determine where it
came from.
Tested all the supplements he was using,
you know,
went through many,
uh,
interviews with Usada,
had a full on arbitration hearing.
Uh,
the source was never determined where it
came from.
Why was his suspension so low or so
short?
Well,
I mean it wasn't that determined.
So I mean there's many factors that go
into what that suspension was.
I would argue in the toe tap totality of
the evidence that was presented in that
arbitration that it,
that it wasn't a short suspension.
Um,
because really one key thing came out at
arbitration.
So John went to arbitration before an
individual by the name of Richard
Mclaren.
Richard Mclaren has an arbitration group
up in Canada and Mclaren is probably
worldwide known as one of the most
credible guys in anti-doping.
I know you had the ICARUS producer
director on the Mclaren report was the
report that came from all that.
He basically investigated the Russian
state being involved in doping and Sochi
Games and put out,
actually a series of reports on it,
detailing it up to 1000 Russian
athletes.
Um,
you know,
we're breaking the rules and the Russian
laboratory was helping them get around
it.
So he's a very,
very respected guy.
He's independent of obviously the UFC.
He's independent of Usada.
Um,
he acts on his own and his determination
was his determination.
And I'll read you kind of what he said.
He said,
I find that all evidence available to me
leads me to conclude that the violation
was not intended,
nor could it have enhanced the athletes'
performance.
So a non-intentional so not
unintentional ingestion.
I mean,
there's no argument that it was in his
system that he found the evidence to
show non-intentional use.
And then he went further saying that
based on the numbers of what he saw and
the evidence that was not even a
performance enhancing benefit afforded
to John for having this longterm
metabolite in his system.
And I think that's significant when you
talk about hey,
15 months is that that's,
you know,
kind of light being that this is the
second time through.
I would argue that if there was an
argument that maybe it's on the higher
end and certainly,
you know,
we'll talk about the California
commission.
Andy Foster took that position,
uh,
in John's recent California hearing,
he was a little bit critical of Usada.
Um,
he thought,
you know,
he's intimately familiar with this
evidence both in the previous case and
this occurrence that,
and he also saw that there was no
evidence that an independent arbitrator,
you know,
made this statement and decision of John
Intentionally cheating.
Um,
so if anything,
you know,
I'd say that potentially there could be
an argument that,
that it was,
you know,
on the higher end versus the lower end
because of the fact that it was an
unintentional ingestion.
Exactly.
Now what is John's excuse?
What is,
what is,
John said how he got this into a system.
We'll look and it's detailed in the
arbitration hearing at all.
John John fully admits that,
you know,
some of the lifestyle,
lifestyle decisions he was making,
you know,
the partying and things,
probably did not lead to making smart
decisions and making smart choices in
terms of what was being ingested in the
body.
But certainly his testimony was under
oath that I have never intentionally
cheated and did not intentionally put
this substance in my body.
And not only this case,
but it as we talk about the subsequent
case here,
I think you'll see that based on the
numbers,
you know,
coming out of his tests and based on
some studies that have been done on some
of these substances,
it would tend to support that.
Okay,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but didn't John tests negative then test
positive for extremely low numbers?
This is the initial test before we get
into the most recent field test she did.
So that's negative then test positive
very shortly after with a very small
trace amounts.
Correct.
So you have two negative tests on July
7th and July 8th,
I believe,
of 2017 and then weigh in day,
I think it was July 28th he was positive
for a very low level of the m three
metabolite and,
and we might as well start here.
So again,
going back to ICARUS,
remember,
remember the doctor,
I mean he's the main character in that
were chink of,
in 2011 he put out a study on oral
Terenna Ball.
Um,
he actually,
my understanding is dosed himself and
then studied the excretion of his urine
and what was coming out of it over the
weeks and months after and determined
that there were multiple maybe up to 50
metabolites that once this Dh cmt was
ingested into the body,
the body converted into other substances
and these metabolites stayed around.
He identified some short term,
some medium term metabolites and some
longterm metabolites,
specifically the m three that John's
tested positive for it.
So these longterm metabolites would
indicate that it was taken long time
ago.
They would stay around for the longest.
Why,
why was he testing negative and then
testing positive for these extremely,
so yeah,
the numbers.
That's a good question and that's,
that's basically the question,
that point.
But what was not occurring and what has
never occurred in any of John's samples
is any presence of the short and medium
term metabolites.
And if you look at a [inaudible] study,
he identifies a couple of these medium
term metabolites,
Roman numeral one and Roman numeral two.
And he says these metabolites based on
his study will stay in the body at least
22 days.
Well,
let's look back to the July 7th and
eighth you know,
positive tests.
He's negative on July 7th and eighth for
everything.
For the parent compound,
for the short term,
medium term term metabolites and the
longterm metabolites go 2021 days later.
So within that 22 day window,
which is study shows the short and
medium term metabolites would still be
showing up and there's no presence
whatsoever of the short or medium term
metabolites.
Now again,
we'll get into this a little bit more,
but I think the science,
what it's showing is a pulsing effect
for this longterm metabolite.
Meaning once you ingest,
whether intentionally or not
unintentionally oral Terenna ball into
the body,
the body breaks it down,
produces short term and medium term,
which is you know,
visible for a short and medium amount of
time.
And then this end three which is
produced for a long period of time.
I think with the issue appears to be,
and we'll get into this,
the UFC program is not the only program
had seen this.
There's another professional sports
league that has seen it very frequently.
You saw it as also seen this on the
Olympic side,
but we're seeing this strange action
with the longterm and three metabolite.
And the theory is it may be hiding in
the fat tissues surrounding organs and
maybe have a pulsing effect where it's
released at certain times and other
times you can't detect it.
And this is not the actual substance
itself,
but it's a metabolite correct.
Which indicates a reaction to this
substance in the body,
breaking down the parent compound the,
the oral Terenna ball and turning it
into these other things which are stored
in the body.
Those metabolites are not performance
enhancing drugs that are the result of
the breakdown of the parent drug in the
body.
How much time is it detectable,
the actual drug itself?
So pretty quick,
uh,
it's a pretty quick clearance time.
I think we're Cenk Golf Studies says,
you know,
maybe a week.
Uh,
so it's not around for very long.
And that's why he conducted the study
ironically enough.
And I was going to go watch bicker is
here last night and I just,
I've had too much going on in the last
week to kind of refresh mind.
But um,
apparently he,
he knew this was part of his protocol
for Russian athletes.
He knew a coach that was still giving
the oral Terenna ball to Russian
athletes and he had a falling out with
the coach.
So he goes off on the side and studies,
Hey,
the parent compound is going to get in
and out of the body pretty quick.
It's going to be difficult to detect
that.
Let's try to figure out what stays
around and leaves markers in the body
for a long time.
And so he developed the short and
longterm metabolite tests and was able
to catch some of this coaches athletes
for using the oral terminable.
Interesting.
So the actual drug itself,
it's gone from the system,
but the metabolite remains.
Now what is the window that the,
this metabolite is supposed to be
detectable in the body?
Cause we're talking now,
what are we at like 18 months?
So here,
here's the show.
Here's the problem is that initial
ingestion,
cause my question is these same longterm
metabolites,
these existed a year plus ago.
It was more than a year.
How long ago that that's the thing.
So July,
2017 was your initial test.
So with all the experts and we'll get
through this with all the experts are
telling us is there is no evidence of re
ingestion and most likely this is still
remnants from the July,
2017 tests.
However it was to enter into a system.
Um,
and we'll go through some of these
testing numbers that have shown
negatives followed by very low level
Pika Pika gram quantities.
You know,
was that the ingestion that happened
that he tested positive for in July of
2017 indicated a long term effect.
Right?
It was a long term term metabolite.
Correct.
So meaning it had already been an
assistant for a year or so.
It absolutely could have predated,
you know,
the theory the first time through was
something had to have entered a system
between July 7th and July 8th those
negatives and this low pika gram reading
on July 28th over this last year,
there's been a lot of study into this
longterm metabolite.
As I mentioned,
this isn't just a UFC issue.
There's another major professional
sports league that for the time being
wants to keep their,
their testing confidential,
but they've shared that information with
scientists,
with Usada,
with myself.
They saw it on multiple occasions.
This pulsing effect over a year where
you'd see this positive tests over a
year.
We're talking two and a half years now.
Right.
If it's a year,
if they,
if it's a,
if in July he had to ride in the 17th
and you were talking a year and a half,
right?
July,
2000 second half.
July 17 but it could have been an
assistant a year prior.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it could have been a couple of months a
year.
I don't know.
He had never showed up for that end
three metabolite for he had been tested
for it.
He had been tested multiple times in the
program from wrong isn't the same level,
isn't it?
Approximately the same Pika grams that
exists today in 2018 that were there in
2017 generally if you look in and we can
go over these numbers,
it,
it fluctuates,
you know,
from single digits and never gets into a
triple digits to,
to mid double digits.
So there's some as low as nine peak of
grams over that time.
Um,
there was some at 60 peak of grants,
however,
a peak grant to someone because it's a
preposterously small.
It's insane.
And you know,
the,
the analogy that I heard early on was,
and I think John uses throw a pinch of
salt and Olympic swimming pool and I'm
like,
okay,
well that's Kinda wrap your head around.
Now let's go the other side.
Let's talk about something really small
that we know of and how many times you
have to break down that small particle
to get to a peak of Graham.
So one grain of salt.
I mean,
we all know what that looks like,
right?
You put that in front of you and you
split that,
and I'd mentioned this week,
50 million,
it's actually 58 million.
If you split that 58 million times a
grain of salt,
each one has a pika gram.
I mean it's incomprehensible the
detection level and how small that is.
It really is.
It's crazy.
And how many peak of grams that they
find in his system.
So he's gone from,
and I'll,
I'll read through it here.
So here's,
here's since the initial appearance of
the n three metabolite,
here's what John's tests look like and
those peak gram reading.
So the first one was collection date was
July 28th,
2017 he had a concentration of ADP
grams.
However,
let me caution and I'll read something
from an expert.
When you get down to these pika gram
levels,
um,
the science is somewhat inexact because
it's such a small amount.
So the variable,
the plus or minus,
you know,
can be anywhere from 2030 I've seen in,
in some instances,
50 or 60.
So what this scientist name,
his name is Larry Bowers.
Um,
he was formerly the,
the Usada Science director.
He's currently retired and independently
consults.
Before that he ran an Olympic,
uh,
Olympic Committee,
a accredited laboratory at the
University of Indiana.
The guy's got 20 to 25 years of
anti-doping experience.
Here's what he,
he told me about,
uh,
you know,
when you're,
when you're analyzing small picogram
levels,
although the two lab,
a respective laboratories report a
concentration,
I would caution against becoming too
fixated on the numbers.
First,
the numbers are really estimates of
concentration and probably should be
considered a range of about plus or
minus 20 picograms per ml.
And he said the December 9th result
would be in the range of John's and
we'll get to that between 60 and a
hundred second while the adjustment of
concentration by specific gravity
attempts to deal with the variability of
urinary excretion rates,
it is an exact,
it is inexact and adds variability to
the estimates.
Finally,
and most importantly,
science has no clear understanding of
the variance of urinary excretion of
drugs at ultra trace concentration.
So basically saying,
look,
I mean we have a general idea how this
works in science but and I think this
instance comes to play,
be real careful if you're to be the guy
with the pseudoscience out there saying,
wait a second,
John jumped from 20 to 60 from September
to December and that means he re
ingested it.
What he's saying here is slow your roll
on that.
That that it's such a small
incomprehensible level that we don't
really know what those variances are
going to look like.
Now I think if we saw jumps and John
from single digit eight or nine peak of
Graham to multiple hundred digit Pika
grams,
there would be a concern and maybe some
meat read administration,
but the experts I've speaking to when
you're talking variability of 10 2030 40
it's not that significant at the peak of
gram level.
What is the window where this longterm
metabolites starts to express itself?
Like what you said,
there's short term and there's medium
term.
This is the long term.
How long does it take before the law?
That's a good question.
I,
I don't have the answer to that.
And maybe in rich hank hubs report here
and I would encourage those that are at
home,
you know,
playing playing scientist at their
computer a,
the journal of steroid biochemistry and
molecular biology.
A Raw Chekhov writes a report detection
and mass spec spectrometric
characterization of novel Longterm
Dehydro Chloro method testosterone
metabolites in human urine.
I'm not sure when that longterm
metabolite,
how long it takes to to show up.
Here's the problem though with this
substance.
He did a real brief study.
My understanding is administered it to
himself.
That's the only study that exists.
Oral Terenna Ball,
DH CMT to my understanding is not
approved for use for human consumption
consumption anywhere,
anywhere in any country.
So you can't have clinical trials
ethically in the medical world because
it's just not legal to give this to
human beings.
So,
you know,
we're,
we're already kind of behind the eight
ball here and that,
you know,
as compared to other substances where
you can do clinical trials because
they're readily available,
would be a per prescription or whatever.
This substance is not,
the substance was created by the East
Germans in the seventies and eighties
and was part of their state sponsored
doping program where they were doping
their athletes.
Can you correct me if I'm wrong,
but I believe what I've read is that
this is particularly effective when
people are cutting weight.
Yeah.
I mean,
is that true or is this just more,
I don't know about that.
I think some may be confusing to
rentable with oral Terenna Ball.
Two completely different substances,
actually.
Very important.
Yeah,
there's,
there's very different effects on the
body.
There's very different windows in terms
of detection time ex explain that.
Yeah.
You gotta be really careful in this
world of performance enhancing drugs.
There's names that are interchangeable.
There's different,
you know,
chemical names where you change a little
bit of that chemical name.
It could mean mean a completely
different substance.
There's instances where the chemical
name is different,
but the substance is actually the same.
So when trying to compare two
substances,
you know,
make sure if you're at home
doing that analysis,
you're comparing the right ones.
Straight Terenna ball is different than
oral to rentable.
What is the difference?
Uh,
yeah,
I,
I can't tell you,
I'm not as familiar with Toronto ball
other than it's not oral to ball.
So,
but there is a difference in terms of
the detection window.
Yeah,
there would be,
I mean,
different substances create and throw
out different metabolites.
Um,
and different substances have different
detection windows.
So I haven't done my study and research
on straight Terenna ball other than
knowing it's different than the
substance here.
So,
uh,
Gregory reaching cough,
that's how you say his last name,
right.
He was the only guy to do an actual
verified study?
Correct.
Now is this study been,
is it been peer reviewed?
Yeah,
I mean it will,
it's,
it's published in the Journal of steroid
biochemistry and molecular biology.
So in order to get something published,
it needs to be peer reviewed.
So it's,
has it been replicated anywhere?
Not that I'm aware of,
no.
So it's just,
so we have one study,
which is really fascinating.
So we know that w first of all,
we know this is an effect of steroid.
We know it works.
Yeah.
These Germans I think show that they
wouldn't have been using it.
Um,
it,
it's not a difficult,
it's not an easy,
easy substance to get ahold of.
Look when it's not approved for use
anywhere in the world,
um,
it's only available on the black market.
Um,
so you'd probably have to go to China to
get it manufactured or you know,
research chemical supply company that's
not supposed to be provided to,
to humans.
Now,
I'm certainly not attributing this to
you,
but there were rumors,
this was one discussion.
Was that one of the possible ways he
could have ingested this.
Um,
and let's be very kind.
John Likes to party.
Okay.
One of the things about partying is
people do cocaine and one of the things
about cocaine is sometimes cocaine is
cut with creatine.
One of the things about creatine is
oftentimes you're buying cheap creatine.
I spent a little,
one of the things that we've had with on
it on,
it's our,
our products are all third party
verified,
but in the initial goings when we tried
different manufacturers,
especially for Alpha brain,
we found there were other trace elements
that were in Alpha brain that weren't
supposed to be in there.
And it's because of the vats that they
mix these things up with.
And one of the things that we had heard
was that creatine oftentimes is made in
the same place where they might be
making oral Terenna Ball,
they might be making animal,
they might be making a bunch of
different things and trace amounts of
this stuff can get into the create team
and they use creatine to cut cocaine
with,
is this,
is this possible or am I just,
yeah,
it's,
it's absolutely a theory.
I don't,
you know,
I,
I can't sit here and said that happened,
but I will have heard similar things.
I have heard similar things.
I know for a fact,
based on my previous career,
I worked closely with the DEA.
I was with the FDA,
I worked cases involving street
distribution of recreational drugs,
including cocaine.
I know for a fact that creatine is one
of the most common substances that
cocaine is cut with because as a similar
look,
some more color,
some more feel.
So getting back to
Mclaren's arbitration decision,
I mean this is publicly available
records,
I'm not saying anything new,
but Mclaren addresses at least John's
lifestyle around this time.
And he says the athlete openly admitted
to Usada that prior to and for a period
of time after the reporting of his
second adverse analytical finding on
July 28 2017 the athlete used illicit so
called street drugs,
including cocaine now,
okay.
For me to sit here and say,
hey,
that's where it came from.
I don't know that.
What's the time period?
He's talking about the,
the athlete admitted,
um,
that prior to and for a period of time
after the reporting of a second adverse
analytical finding on July 27,
2017 admitted.
So before that test and sometime after.
Okay.
So does that make sense though?
If it,
it's cut.
If that's what where the,
the source of it is,
does it make sense that that would show
up as a longterm metabolite?
Doesn't it need a long time in the body
to digest or do we not know enough about
the window of time?
Yeah.
I don't know if we know enough about the
window of time.
You know my,
my theory and looking at it is even if
there's a small amount of the oral
Terenna ball in that it's going to for a
period of time,
show that parent compound at a small
peak of gram amount and the short and
midterm metabolites in the small peak
gram amount.
We have never seen those in the history
of Johns testing.
It's only this longterm metabolite.
So that may be indication that it
occurred.
Maybe even prior to what we're talking
about here.
Is it something that could be
accentuated in some way by the weight
cutting process?
I absolutely think that could be a
factor.
Um,
there are studies not necessarily with
this,
but another substance clomiphene and
look,
I want,
while I'm cautioning people to be
careful about comparing different
substances,
the commonality between Clomiphene,
which there are multiple clinical
studies on cause it is approved for use
to be distributed to humans and oral
Terenna ball is or both chlorinated.
So they both contain a chlorine atom on
the molecule.
And there is a recently published study
on clomiphene and its excretion rates.
Um,
again for those at home that want to
look it up.
The study was published in the endocrine
society publication.
It's pure reviewed,
the name of it is hpt axis affects and
urinary detection following clomiphene
administration and males.
So what they did is they basically,
you know,
got a group of males,
um,
gave them a one month,
cycle of clomiphene,
you know,
I think 25 milligrams a day and then
have them get off and then continue to
look at their year and up to 261 days
after.
And what you saw and what you see in
this study is that pulsing effect.
So,
you know,
I'm looking at some of the studies
subjects here.
Um,
subject one on day one 21 still showed
147 Pika grams of clomiphene day one 28
showed 174 pika grams.
Day One 35 shows nothing.
He's below the minimum courting,
uh,
reporting limit.
And then day one 49,
he's back up to two 36.
There are one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six out of I think 12 subjects in that
study that showed this pulsing effect of
this chlorinated substance coming and
going again.
You know,
it's,
it's different than oral Terenna Ball,
but it has that common factor of being
chlorinated in this study.
They do talk about,
um,
a fat tissue called the,
let me look this up and make sure I got
this right.
Adipose tissue,
this is fat that surrounds the internal
organs.
It's one of the last things that the
body burns when it's going,
you know,
starving itself and going to fat.
It protects those organs.
But yeah,
you look at these,
you know,
extreme weight gains and cuts that the
UFC athlete goes through.
I don't think you're going to find
possibly another human subject anywhere
that goes through putting weight on
other than maybe that,
I don't think Olympic wrestling matches
with an MMA fighter,
um,
goes through,
at least in my experience over these
three or four years talking to those in
the Olympic world.
I think we're at the extreme and it's,
it's something obviously we've talked
about before,
we're trying to curtail,
but you know,
there's,
there's clearly never been a study for
anybody who dehydrates and readwrite
hydrates themselves to the extent that
some of our athletes do.
You could never find,
there would never be anybody with any
ethics that would support a study
because some of that dehydration exceeds
World Health Organization standards.
So there's no studies out there,
you know,
on this stuff.
But clearly,
you know,
looking from afar I,
I'd say that it likely has some impact
over what's being released by this
adipose tissue.
We should certainly talk about that in
the future,
about the,
the weight cutting aspect of it.
So,
but this adipose tissue loss at extreme
weight cuts could potentially be the
reason why this stuff is excluding
itself.
It's,
it's definitely a theory out there.
What about micro dosing?
So here's the thing with microdosing
microdosing has done with indogenous
substances.
So only test,
well,
I mean someone could try it with
something else,
but the reason you microdose with
endogenous substances is there already
produced in the body,
right?
So the theory of,
okay,
I'm going to microdose oral Terenna
Ball,
we'll oral Terenna ball still producing
these short term and longterm
metabolites in theory,
whether you're taking a hundred
milligrams or one milligram of oral
Terenna Ball,
those excretion rates of those
metabolites are still going to be
consistent.
They're going to be in a much smaller
level or a way to those excretion rates.
Is there a way to mask that in some way?
I'm not aware of any,
um,
I'm sorry.
The only study we have is Gregory,
correct?
That's it.
Correct.
But you know,
just taking it from a common sense
approach,
it's certainly,
you know,
those that know about micro grossing
know that you microdose with endogenous
substances,
things that are already pouring in the
body so your body knows what to do with
them.
Those what to do.
And you're fooling,
you know,
not only are these metabolizing and
there's no metabolites of them,
but you could also be fooling the
biological passport.
That's the concern I think and why
people microdose.
So you saw it as looking not only
testing for specific substances,
but our testosterone epitestosterone
ratio is going up.
They're looking at at blood values,
how many young red blood cells,
how many mature red blood cells.
So microdosing and those two areas
wouldn't set off alarms in the
biological passport world.
Um,
I've never heard personally of
microdosing of exotic his substances
that are not found in the body.
Microdosing and my understanding has
done with things that are endogenous
body for people that are not familiar
with this terminology,
we were just talking about microdosing
performance enhancing drugs because a
micro dosing in today's world is a very
common thing with mushrooms and Lsd.
And a lot of,
I mean I saw a ton of microdosing in
the,
in the cycling world that was test
towels,
testosterone,
epo,
hgh,
all those natural occurring in the body
and said,
I don't produce any really a red flag
metabolites if you do them.
At very,
very small levels.
They'll,
the parent will clear quickly not
produce any metabolites and will not
throw off the biological passport
analysis.
Um,
is there a what you mean when Victor
Conte came out with a clear and all that
stuff with ball co,
they were fooling people.
Is it,
is it,
I mean one of the things that we've
talked about before is that it's a
constant race to try to keep up with
more advanced cheaters.
It is.
And,
and you know what's interesting in this,
I mean,
if I were to talk to you and maybe the
first time we did talk a couple of years
ago,
um,
it,
it's come a long way from them,
but clearly if I would have talked to
you 15,
16,
17 years ago when I got my start in the
anti-doping world,
I would have told you definitively the
testing is way behind,
you know,
what's being used out there.
Um,
they were testing,
able to test to multiple nanogram,
um,
limits.
That's as far down as we can go.
Now they can go down to single digit
Pika,
gram.
There's another professional sports
league out there that recently had a one
pika gram and three metabolite case.
I mean do the math coming down from you
know,
four or five nanograms,
which used to be the lower limit now to
one Pika Gram ten thousand twenty
thousand times.
I am almost under the theory that the
pendulum has swung maybe a little bit
too far in the other direction and that
that certainly is part of my job to the
UFC.
Look,
I want catch every intentional cheater
that's out there.
I want to make sure we have a rock solid
program,
use all the latest and greatest,
you know,
um,
techniques to do it.
But I also want to keep an eye on it to
make sure it's being administrated
fairly.
And when you're getting down to
detection of one,
you know,
single digit Pika Grams,
I have a concern that what kind of level
of sensitivity we're talking about.
Are we going to talk about environmental
contamination where you walk through a
room and somebody has just opened a
container of something and there's,
you know,
minuscule powders in the air.
There are documented cases that some of
the regularly prescribed prescription
drugs,
specifically diuretics are getting in
water supplies in some areas.
You know,
you get a lot of old people on them that
flushed their old pills down the toilet.
There's documented cases of it getting
into the water supply and being
detectable at that peak at ground level.
So you've gotta be really,
really careful about that.
And I think,
you know,
this case exemplifies that you saw it
and,
and really the world antidoping agency
world and community are aware of that.
Um,
you know,
with greater sensitivity and testing in
my opinion,
because you know,
makes greater responsibility to be
objective and look fairly at what really
we're doing here when we're detecting
and that small amount.
But this,
this task of John's where he's testing
for the same level of peak of Graham's
today as he was in July of 2017 is it
safe to say that this is unprecedented?
Repeat that again,
that John's test for the same levels of
peak of grams of these metabolites in
2018 that he was testing for in 2017
this is unprecedented.
No.
If the answer's no,
it's so maybe I'm precedent and in the
UFC program,
but what the United States anti-doping
agency did over these last five or six
months as they reached out to the
science community outside the scope of
the UFC,
they reached out to other professional
sports organizations.
They reached out to otherwise water
laboratories and what they were seeing
was multiple instances of this pulsing
effect where over time you would see a
reading,
the next test it would go away and the
next time you'd see that reading again,
maybe back up to or even above this much
time was correct.
Yes.
So you see that in the,
in the clomiphene study here too,
I mean almost 260 they stopped the
study,
what it was still appearing and Pika
gram levels in some subjects and they
stopped the study at 261 days.
And you see those numbers I was reading
to you.
See this one subject at one 74,
he's negative the next time and then he
pops up to two in the two hundreds
after.
So it's actually more than the time
before.
Again,
apples and oranges,
different substances.
But the commonality here is chlorinated
substance.
So is the,
is it safe to say that this is an
emerging science and that we're still
learning and understanding this as we go
along?
Absolutely.
It's still very young.
Look,
the first,
you know,
the 1984 Olympics in Los Angeles were
established the first drug testing
laboratory by Doctor Catlin.
Um,
so really,
you know,
in the scope of science going back to
the earliest days,
then are talking about,
you know,
what,
30,
30 years,
35 years.
Um,
again,
when I started off in this 16 or 17
years,
the science still wasn't good.
They were unable to detect anything.
And the peak of gram level,
um,
again for reference,
very interesting.
So the,
the Wada,
the world anti-doping agencies accredits
laboratories across the world and they
have certain standards that those
laboratories must meet or to retain that
accreditation and keep that
accreditation.
So they have a technical document called
the minimum required performance levels
of their laboratory.
So would they tell the laboratories is
you must detect these substances down to
this amount.
If you can't get them down to this
amount,
then you can't have an accreditation
from water.
So the class of substances that oral
Terenna ball would be in,
um,
which would be other anabolic agents,
the required minimum level that they
must attack two is only two nanograms.
So look,
watch,
it even says,
as long as you can get to two nanograms,
you can retain our accreditation.
Well what's happening is an arms race in
these laboratories,
they're saying,
well two's the minimum standard but I
can get down further.
And you know,
these are private entities that you
know,
are looking for customers.
So to be able to reach out and say,
well even though a lot of tells us too
is as low as we need to go,
we can go down to one pika gram.
I think in a sense,
maybe you need to slow the reigns on
that a little bit.
That we're getting too far and too
sensitive of a level of detection when
it comes to implementing a fair program
because you can't determine where a one
pika gram co came from.
You could be breathing again,
contaminated air,
drinking contaminated water.
It gets real dangerous when you get down
that low.
Now how does this reflect on past
suspensions?
This is a what when you,
you deal with something like,
look,
let's bring up Frank Mir for example.
Didn't frank near also test for oral,
turn the ball.
Okay,
I want to get back to Frank Mir but
let's,
let's go back to John and this instance
and why you saw it.
It has come out and said,
look,
this is not a violation.
So if you go to the Wada,
the world anti-doping code,
there's a section 10.7
0.4
0.1
are UFC program.
You know,
basically mirrors that and we're
bringing that up on the screen there.
So for purposes of imposing sanctions
under tab 10.7
and anti doping rule violation will only
be a second
violation if the anti-doping
organization can establish the athlete
or other person committed.
The second anti-doping rule violation
after the athlete or other person
received notice pursuant to article
seven et Cetera.
This is what's known as a double
jeopardy clause.
The sanction test positive for something
and if he's test positive for the exact
same substance that is still in his
system a year later or whatever the
amount of time is,
you don't include that as a new positive
tasks.
One more thing has to happen.
Science has to determine that there
hasn't been a real administration so
test positive for the same substance and
science says based on all the numbers we
see,
there is no evidence of any readminister
ration and the non evidence of the
readministered nation is the lack of
short term and medium term singling.
Never ever.
And John's or an issue though that this
is only one test that gregory would
shank goes test is the only study that
showed at these medium and short term
metabolites exist.
It's the only study,
but I think then if there's only one
study,
you have to go to anecdotal evidence.
Right?
Why don't we do studies on UFC employees
because we're all Toronto Ball.
He'll do it.
Oral Terenna ball is illegal to
distribute what's due to Mexico and any
country throughout the world.
It's really eagle.
Every contracts go,
they just let you do whatever you want
to do.
I don't know,
maybe we can look into that,
but shelby may be out for that.
And that's the reason for living there.
Um,
I,
I have a problem with that in that we're
relying on one study.
This seems to me to be like a,
a critical thing that could affect,
I mean we're,
we're,
we're hoping and we're,
uh,
we're putting faith in this study that
this is the only way that these
metabolites express themselves.
Is it possible that,
what,
that these be like,
you see what the pulsing effect that you
see positive effects and negative or
positive results and negative results
that these short term and medium term
metabolites don't always express
themselves and that what we're
considering a longterm metabolite could
in fact just be a metabolite.
Yeah.
I,
I mean,
I guess it's possible,
but what are you,
are you going to sanction and athlete
again because you know,
potentially it's possible.
And then the theory of that universe.
You can't do that.
Let me read it to you real quick.
What,
what these experts came out at and terms
of readministered ration.
So Dr.
Daniel Eichner runs the Salt Lake City.
It's called a smart sports medicine
research testing laboratory,
or smurter.
They're one of two water accredited
laboratories in the United States.
The other one being a ucla,
um,
again,
one of the most respected minds in
anti-doping phd chemist.
Um,
his answer in terms of readminister
ration,
um,
was this,
and you very rarely see scientists at
his level talk in a absolute absolute.
So there you go.
And here he says,
there is no evidence that Dh cmt has
been readministered that's in writing to
us.
So very definitive on that,
right.
Um,
you saw it as science director now,
Dan Daniels independent even of Usada.
So those who criticize,
Hey,
you saw it as in bed with the UFC.
Daniel lackner doesn't work for you.
Soda.
He runs an independent laboratory.
You sought to send samples there.
The NFL send samples,
they're major league baseball,
send samples there.
The NCA,
he's independent,
owns his own laboratory.
Um,
you saw to also put out,
um,
a letter to us in,
in writing,
um,
upon careful consideration of the very
low concentration of the DH cmt longterm
metabolite.
And Mr.
Jones is sample and taking into account
the Human Pharma kinetic characteristics
of this particular longterm anabolic
steroid metabolites,
uh,
based on data to which you saw to,
has access to and in consult,
in consultation with scientific experts,
some of whose opinions aren't close,
you sought.
It has concluded consistent with prior
residual amounts detected.
And Mr.
Jones sample that the presence of Dh cmt
longterm metabolite is consistent with
residual amounts from exposure prior to
to that July 28th,
2017.
Um,
look,
I'm not,
I'm not an expert.
I don't profess to be,
um,
my,
my background's in finance and
accounting.
I traced the money back in the old days,
but I know who those experts are out
there in the world and these are them.
Um,
they're my putting these things in
writing,
putting their reputations on the line
now and forever going forward.
Um,
they're never going to do something like
that because you know,
the UFC pays,
you sought it to administer our program
or because Jon Jones is,
you know,
a popular fighter and they want to see
him fight this weekend.
That's just not the way this world
works.
Of course in in fact it works the
opposite way.
There would be a great benefit if they
could catch him cheating.
Absolutely.
And you know,
historically experts like this are very,
very conservative when it comes to
talking in absolutes like this.
They don't normally do it.
In all fairness.
The real question is guys like you and
me because we are UFC employees,
so we got to handle this fairly yet.
That argument,
you know,
and I saw that left and right that hey,
jeff and joe are paid by the UFC.
Of course they're going to come out and
this way,
but look,
all these things that I'm reciting
today,
we do that in regards to cheating,
I would either,
I've,
I side with the UFC on a lot of things
because I support the sport.
I wanted to excel.
I don't side ever with cheating.
If I think that there's some way somehow
that someone has given an unfair
advantage and this is somehow being
covered up,
I would rather not work for them.
Joe,
my seven,
my last 17 years of my career,
my,
you know,
everything that I've worked for is to
protect the rights of clean athletes and
to eradicate cheating from the sport.
I can't tell you how strongly I feel
about that.
Sports given me everything in my life.
My Dad was a high school basketball
coach.
Um,
it paid for my college and scholarships.
It,
you know,
at least the good characteristics in me.
I can all trace directly to sports and
entering into the equation the issues of
breaking the rules,
the issues of the health and safety
aspects when you have young,
and I talked to many parents whose kids,
you know,
use steroids because they saw the
professional athletes doing,
answering that into the body when your
homeowner levels are already out of
control is very,
very dangerous.
Both short and longterm.
Can't tell you how passionate I am about
this issue.
And those out there that are saying that
I'm corrupt and my reputation has is out
the window.
I would never ever in a million years
sales people,
I mean you obviously you have,
but you just,
you can't listen to those people because
they want to find things wrong.
Um,
one of the things that I've said about
you is you're a guy loves to catch
people cheating.
You like it,
you enjoy it.
That's not true,
man.
You do.
I don't mind if someone is cheating and
you catch them in the UFC program now
with what we've established here.
Absolutely.
Back in the old days,
and we've talked about this,
look when you had in baseball or in
cycling,
no testing going on.
Literally the organizations were looking
in the other direction.
I've often said that,
look,
I don't agree with what they did,
but there's a portion of me and that's
why I think a lot of these athletes
respected me and share that information.
But there's a portion of me that said,
I don't agree with what you did.
I like to think I wouldn't make the same
decision,
but I damn well understand why you did
this.
You're fighting for millions of dollars
in contracts.
You know your teammates are doing it,
you know your competitors are doing it
and your know your professional sports
organization doesn't give a shit because
of the weakness of the testing program
or total lack thereof.
So in instances like that,
there was,
I never came away saying that guy's an
idiot or an asshole for choose.
And I came away saying,
I kind of get why he did it.
If I was 21 or 22 years old and
immature,
I may have made the same decision.
Now come into our program here where you
have an organization that cares very
much,
that spends multimillion dollars a year.
This program has done nothing but costs
the UFC money.
It costs us money and how we implement
the program costs us money on canceling
fights.
Anybody who thinks moving this fight to
California is that a financial benefit
to the UFC is crazy.
We're taking a bath on this one.
People really do need to understand that
the UFC decided themselves,
they self imposed.
You sought as sanctioning of fights.
Correct.
Nobody forced us to do that.
So this is a,
this was a big step in the right
direction of trying to make the sport
cleaner because we recognize that first
of all,
there was some legal stuff with the
testosterone replacement therapy that
just threw everything out of whack.
Right.
Where it was essentially it was
sanctioned cheating.
I mean,
let's be honest about what that was.
It was,
it was clearly a my understanding being
manipulated.
Yeah.
I'm the very easy to manipulate when you
get permission to use any prohibited
substance like that.
And we went from that to unbelievably
strict protocols.
And now what you're seeing is you're
seeing,
first of all,
we saw a radical change in the physiques
of some fighters where we,
we did have some suspicions and those
suspicions,
at least in my eyes had been confirmed.
And now we're seeing the good side of
this with what in your estimation might
have been moved over into a position
where okay now now it's getting a little
bit ridiculous in terms of like what we
can detect and what is,
what is causing fights to be canceled.
Exactly.
So interestingly enough,
the world antidoping agency,
a lot of their next code revision is
2021 and so they regularly put out,
hey,
what are the issues going forward that
we want to address?
And one of the major issues is
potentially establishing thresholds for
these low level substances that keep
appearing.
Um,
DH cmt being one of them,
Austrian being one of them.
And so the idea that water is looking at
and has a working group of worldwide
experts is,
hey,
if if something that gets reported back
and under 50 Pika grams,
all the evidence is showing,
more likely than not,
this is from a very low level
contaminant issue.
We've never seen an issue of a micro
dosing or an intentional use that's
reached that level.
Why are the labs even reporting at sub
at quantities lower than 50 pika grams
or 100 peak grounds?
I think very soon they're going to come
out with a recommendation.
We are going to adopt that before 2021
once that working group and we're in
communication with them,
comes up with those recommendations.
You'll see it it implement it first in
the UFC program,
again,
I've always said fairness.
Due process in a program is just as
important as the strength and
comprehension,
comprehensiveness of that program.
You'll lose faith in your athletes.
You could have the strongest loophole
free program in the world,
but you start implement tink things
unfairly.
You'll lose faith just as much as if you
had a bunch of loopholes in the program.
It's got to be fair.
Are you aware of the female skier that
tested positive because of lip balm?
I think,
yeah,
it's vaguely recall about that.
What was someone else use the lip balm
before her?
No,
no,
no.
It was a,
uh,
a lip balm for sunburn.
It was for sunburnt lips and it had some
ridiculously small trace amount.
Was it Austin Green cv?
Give her name?
Is Jo Jo Burg?
Trying to remember her name?
Well,
there was the,
the cocaine kissing defense was actually
one an arbitration.
So something similar,
somebody tested positive for,
you know,
low level metabolites,
a cocaine and basically said,
look,
you know,
hey,
whether that was good or not,
but um,
you know,
the arbitrator bought it and the science
shows,
hey that,
that is a possibility.
The detection levels are so low.
If you kiss somebody who had just done
cocaine,
they're now able to detect at those
levels in the,
the person that kiss that person.
That makes sense.
Do you find this woman doping label on
the label,
which is why they gave her a penalty
apparently.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
What is the,
um,
who fucks reading labels on lip off,
you know what I mean?
See,
that's,
that's how crazy it's gotten.
I mean,
all our athletes know when,
when they're using a creatine or a
protein or whatever,
I think most of them are pretty careful
right now.
But to tell them,
hey,
you need to read your lip balm and your
deodorant.
I mean,
where,
what level are we get into here?
And these are the levels of detection.
So she 21,
nine year old starved Norway's
powerhouse squad of a skiing cross
country skiing tested positive for an
hour anabolic agent listed in the
contents of a treatment for sunburn.
Um,
this could be similar in some ways to
what Chad Mendez tested positive for,
for something for psoriasis.
Correct.
Sat chatman is,
has obvious psoriasis.
You'd see it on his body.
He's talked about it pretty openly and
to use some sort of a cream and accepted
his penalty wasn't a word of this cream
had something,
some type of a steroid into it.
Yeah.
I had seen him publicly state that now
he chose not to present a defense or go
to arbitration.
So I haven't seen anything in detail to
you.
He just rode knowledgeable on that.
Yeah,
he did.
What?
So let's get back to the Frank Mir case.
Frank near tested positive was it also
also same thing,
longterm metabolite of world Terenna
Ball.
Here's the difference.
Frank Mir as the same as John Jones.
His first time through was sanctioned.
John didn't get off the first time that
showed up in his system.
He got,
you know,
he was looking at potential for years,
went to arbitration,
presented evidence and act as some other
clauses in the policy that reduced his
sanction.
What does that mean?
Uh,
well,
one of them was uh,
um,
substantial assistance where he assisted
Usada and some way,
shape or form and he got a reduction
for,
for doing that.
Assisted in what way?
So I don't know.
And this is the exact reason why I do
this.
So I insulate myself from that
interaction between you sought it and
the athlete,
they are the soldier to adjudicate or in
this they do not.
You know,
get me on the phone and say,
hey,
we're thinking about going this way.
They adjudicate completely in a vacuum
and you are,
you're just so people know.
Your title is safety,
health and safety.
Athlete health and performance.
Vice President of athlete health and
performance.
Yeah.
So you no longer work for you saw it.
It never worked for Usada.
That's,
that's a big misconception a lot of our
fighters think that I've never worked
for,
you saw it.
I was a federal agent for 22 and a half
years.
Um,
the latter part of my career got
involved with all these ped distribution
cases.
2015 Lorenzo Fertitta and Dana white
through a mutual friend contacted me and
said,
hey,
would you come out and kind of talk to
us?
We're contemplating maybe putting our
own program together.
We've had some recent high profile
positive.
So I came out to vegas a talk with them
and a week later I get a phone call
asking if I want to come work for him
and kind of implement this new program.
But I've never been an employee of
Usada.
Okay.
So that's,
that's good to know because that's been
stated by some public figures that you
used to work for Usada and now you work
for the UFC.
Never that on a shale.
That's one of my favorite words.
Um,
so you never worked for you soda,
you,
uh,
brought Usada to the UFC or communicated
with Usada and facilitated this
agreement.
Correct.
So I never worked for Usada.
I did work very closely with Usada.
So you saw that when I first started
these series of investigations back in
2002,
look,
I knew all about how to work a heroin
distribution organization and cocaine
distribution organization,
methamphetamine.
But when it came to performance
enhancing drugs,
there was no class that myself or really
any other federal agent or law
enforcement agent goes through
surrounding distribution of performance
enhancing drugs.
So I was examining the discarded garbage
of Balco every week when they put it out
to the curb,
began seeing notes,
rappers,
all these substances.
I had no idea what these things were.
I didn't know the difference between
testosterone epitestosterone,
arithroid tin,
hgh.
I knew nothing.
So what I did is I figured out who those
experts were,
who were the people that could very
quickly get me up to speed on what I was
looking at.
Um,
doctor Catlin who ran the UCL Olympic
loud was one of the first and he
started,
um,
you know,
kind of walking me through this.
He put me in touch with Usada and you
know,
they began educating me as well.
So,
um,
over the course of those investigations,
I got a lot from them in terms of
educating on the substances.
They were bringing some of their
cooperating witnesses to me and then we
go off and running on criminal
investigations.
Um,
but never,
never worked for them.
So you sought a,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but the way they would work would be
very compartmentalized.
Like they would not specifically
communicate with you on all of the
details of this.
Correct.
And they don't now,
I mean,
you don't,
independence aspect.
I don't as these deliberations are going
on what they're looking at,
I don't know.
It's cooperation.
Just for me to be Frank Wood in my eyes
would mean that something was done
purposely illegally and this person had
some knowledge of purpose,
purposeful,
illegal activity,
and that they would somehow communicate
this to facilitate some sort of catching
of someone involved in a criminal act or
an act of cheating.
Yeah,
that,
that would make sense to me too.
Yeah.
That would be what we were talking
about.
Usada would allow John a shorter
suspension if he actively participated
in helping them catch people that were
cheating that that's the understanding.
I don't know,
implied that would be implied.
I don't know to what level that was
done.
I don't know if it was that or if it
was,
hey,
here's how this drug works in more
general.
Here's the,
I don't know what it was.
I purposely,
that would mean that John would have to
know about cheating.
If you're saying like this,
this is how this jug drug works.
This is how I used it.
I mean,
this would,
he would,
that would mean his initial defense
would have to be thrown out the window
because it wasn't an accident.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know about that.
If you knew something separate from,
you know,
that he wasn't someone else.
Yeah.
And again,
I don't,
I don't want anybody to reach that
conclusion.
I have no idea what his substantial
assistance entailed.
None.
Um,
and it's a slippery slope.
It is a slippery slope and look,
transparency's important in any program,
but you know,
only to a certain level,
look,
if you are transparent about what
everyone's,
you know,
cooperation or substantial assistant was
and the whole world knew about it,
you're never going to get anybody after
that coming in and,
and,
and cooperating.
I saw this definitely on the criminal
side with informants,
you don't,
that's not something that's,
that you want to be transparent about or
disclose.
Right.
But there's going to be a bunch of
people that have a real issue with that.
And the idea that Jon Jones,
you know,
one of the greatest fighters of all time
is actually working as an informant.
I mean it's,
it's listed in the,
in the,
you know,
in the Mclaren's ruling that that was
one of the reasons for the mitigating
factor and the reduction.
But I don't,
again,
I know nothing about to leave that alone
and about it.
It's been stated,
we know what it is.
Okay.
Or we know that it's a thing.
Um,
when it comes to the John's initial test
where he was sanctioned and was
suspended for a determined period of
time,
Frank Mir also was sanctioned for a
determined period of time as well.
He was two years.
He was,
John was shorter than that.
John was sean cooperate on a bunch of
other deal.
[inaudible] not only cooperative,
he went to arbitration and put on a
defense.
He put on a defense that,
look,
the evidence here shows no intentional
ingestion of it.
And in fact the Clara and gave him a
further reduction based on,
there was no evidence of this was
intentionally done.
Frank Mir didn't put on any,
he had every right to go to arbitration
put on his own offense.
Didn't do that.
What about Josh Barnett?
Uh,
Josh Barnett,
you know,
a completely different set of facts.
His came from a contaminated supplement.
It was a different substance.
He went to an arbitration hearing,
the arbitrator ruled with Josh and said,
Yep,
you know,
based on where we are now based on the
care and effort that you took your
right,
you deserve to have time served at the
time of that arbitration.
So again,
I think that's a good example of the
checks and balances in place here.
You've gotten me overseeing the program,
taking a look at how these things come
out.
You've got the ability from the athlete
to go to Mclaren's group and judge,
you know,
the set of facts.
And in that case,
Mclaren's group said you saw Usada I
think maybe overreached a little bit
here and I believe Josh and Josh is,
you know,
basically time served.
So you know,
you want to see,
you want to see them get it perfect,
right every time.
But you know,
and the reality in the real world is
that doesn't necessarily happen and
that's why you have these checks and
balances available.
Um,
Josh Barnett take on.
The matter is that they tried to paint
him as guilty even though he was not and
that he,
he feels like he definitely got a bad
deal and that he was labeled as someone
who is taking this substance.
He was suspended for a long period of
time when he was going through this and
although he was found not guilty that he
feels like not enough emphasis was put
into establishing that he was not guilty
and that you know,
he,
he feels like they chased him down over
something that he didn't do.
Yeah,
I mean we'll,
well here's what he did do is he used a
supplement that if he would have
listened to anything that we educate on
that you sought a sends out regular
reminders are fighters are required on a
quarterly basis to go through videos and
their whereabouts,
filing that deals with these issues.
If he would have followed any of that
advice when it came to his supplement
choices,
he would have never chosen the
supplement he used.
I,
you know,
when,
when I heard about that supplement and
what was on the label and how it was
marketed,
I said,
okay,
well that's,
that's likely the candidate of where it
came from.
Yeah.
So I mean,
the analysis would be,
hey,
you know,
that pool will be careful.
There's sharks swimming in that pool.
It can eat you.
And the person jumps in the water anyway
saying,
look,
I didn't want to get eaten by a shark,
but a shark comes up and aid them.
It's like,
Hey,
we told you that this was the case.
She didn't follow that.
Now there also needs to be a
differentiation between someone who's
intentional,
cheating,
intentionally cheating,
and someone that's just,
you know,
makes a naive supplement choice.
There.
There needs to be a differentiation
between that.
And there was,
and that case Josh didn't get,
you know,
the full penalty of what was,
what that substance,
you know,
would have rendered,
but he did have to go through a long
period of time where he was unable to
fight.
He did.
But you know,
again,
he had the prohibited substance in his
body.
Um,
as you saw it,
it has to look at,
Hey,
even though you did that,
didn't do that on purpose,
did that give you a performance
enhancing benefit?
Did it allow you to recover a little bit
better?
Did it make you a little bit stronger?
And you know,
that's why those strict liability
provisions are in there.
Otherwise people would just take these
prohibited supplements and say,
Oh,
I didn't know exactly it was an
accident.
Meanwhile,
they're getting a benefit for exactly.
So they have to have some sort of
penalty in place.
I think so,
yeah.
I also think,
again,
there needs to be a differentiation
between the intentional non-intentional
and we do have that in our policy.
There are definitely mitigating factors
available in our policy that if you
didn't do thing on purpose,
you're not,
you know,
you're not sanctioned as tim means is a
great example there.
So Tim means use a relatively benign
supplement.
It was a creatine,
creatine,
you know,
generally doesn't have an issue as,
as,
as opposed like testosterone booster
supplements.
We tell our athletes stay away from
anything marketing as a testosterone
booster.
It's one of the most common with
contaminants are purposely spiking
purposeful.
Spikings two means uses a Korea 10.
It had a asta and in a very small
amount,
uh,
we founded in there,
you know,
Austrian has to your sanction.
He got six months,
um,
you know,
so back relatively quickly.
So I think that's the thing with Yoel
Romero.
So correct.
Yoel Romero used a natural diuretic
product that had um,
a SAR minute.
Um,
and all of these cases,
not only does the prohibited substance
need to show up and with the athlete has
says they've used ready but to protect
against making sure the athlete isn't
purposely spiking it.
You saw it,
we'll go out on their own,
on the market,
independently procure,
hopefully the same lot of product.
And in the case of eol and Tim,
they were able to do that,
test it completely independently of the
athlete,
determine what level the prohibited
substances in that based on the
interview with the athlete of how much
did you use,
when's the last time you used it
relative to this test?
Do the science calculations just to make
sure an athlete's not saying,
well I know this Korea tennis spiked
with fostering,
so I'm going to go use Austrian.
And then I have a built in excuse when I
test positive for Australian in order to
be able to match contaminant levels with
what's being excreted in the urine,
you would literally have to have phd
chemistry degree and I'm not aware of of
any our athletes have in that,
it'd be very,
very difficult to do that.
And so these detection levels,
again we're talking about nanograms,
we're not talking about large
quantities.
That would be a pika grams.
Correct.
Now what,
why was,
why was this moved from Vegas to
California and why?
Why did the California State Athletic
Commission,
why did they accept this fight taking
place here and why did Vegas say no to
it?
So internally,
the UFC wise,
we first,
in fact Donna Mark Illini who you know
who works with me,
uh,
we're out to Donna.
Exactly.
We're a two person shop and the woman's
a hawks and one of the hardest workers I
know.
So she's,
she's awesome.
She's taken a look at something that we
have access to called the clearing
house.
And it's basically a recording of all
the tests on our athletes.
So we can get on there.
Somebody says,
Hey,
how many times was John Tested last
quarter?
We can get on there and pull that up.
The public also has access to our
testing records,
not with a specificity that the
clearinghouse has,
but the public can get on.
And you saw it on a weekly basis.
Um,
updates how many tests and athletes
done.
So there's some of these,
some guys out there on the Internet from
the day one of the program have kept
track of what week they're numbers tick
up.
So you can go find spreadsheets on the
Internet,
at least from a,
from a weekly basis of when our athletes
were tested and how many times every
week.
God bless those dorks.
Crazy.
Huh?
So the clearing house program is very
specific.
We can get on there and see the actual
date of the collection.
And next to that we see negative,
positive or pending.
So Donna came to me late November,
early December saying,
Hey,
I'm looking at John's tests and I'm
seeing pending still back from I think
was maybe August,
September,
thinks something's going on here.
And of course I'm like,
okay,
well he's fighting pretty soon.
I hope not,
but let me reach out to you Sada.
So I reached out to them.
They said,
we're working on something.
We're,
you know,
conducting a study.
We're talking to other professional
sports leagues.
We're talking to the laboratories out
there and don't have an answer for you
now that,
but stand by.
So I think it was September,
December six,
they sent a letter to us and they sent a
letter to the Nevada state athletic
commission saying,
just so you're aware,
over the last six months,
um,
early in this six months,
we've seen a reemergence of this
longterm metabolite,
uh,
in John's samples,
we've always was this.
So this was early December,
December 6th,
we and the Nevada Athletic Commission
were notified.
You were notified,
but the test was from previous.
So the tests,
these tests,
um,
covered from August through November.
Okay.
So there's [inaudible] test several of
them.
Oh,
some more than one test show this
metabolite.
So what they said was August 9th,
negative August 29th,
eight picograms September 18th,
eight eight September 18th.
So I mean there's a,
there's a good,
so he's negative on the ninth 20 days
later.
So inside the 22 checkups,
22 day window,
he shows an eight peak gram,
no short term metabolites,
no longterm,
no parent,
no medium term,
no medium.
I'm sorry.
No media.
Only longterm.
Thank you.
Um,
we then go to the 18th of September,
19 Pika grams and then that's followed
by four negative tests.
September 21st,
October 2nd,
October 11th and November 14th.
So at this point,
late November,
early December,
you saw it and says,
okay,
we've done our studying those two low
levels in August,
our residual,
there's no evidence of any readminister
ration based on lack of short and medium
term and parent.
Um,
based on our consultation with other
leagues with these labs that are seeing
this,
we're calling this,
this is would be double jeopardy if we
did them again.
Okay,
this is awesome.
This is something that should be really
emphasized because there's a lot of
people that don't understand this.
This is not just this one test.
These are many tasks that have been done
over course of John's suspension and
then ultimately relicensing that are
showing this exact same metabolite at a
very similar level that according to
previous tests,
specifically on Clomiphene,
that this could be this pulsing correct
result of existing and not existing.
But this is not indicative in any way
that can be provable of microdosing.
Correct.
And not only that,
but this is over.
We're talking about this being over long
term,
long periods of time.
Many months.
Okay.
And consistent numbers over many months.
So,
and again,
going back to what one expert Dr.
Bauer said,
you've gotta be careful what you're
talking about.
He's single and double wall number,
grams.
And you see some bearings.
You gotta be careful about saying,
well it went from nine to 18 that means
re administration.
No,
it's inexact science at that level.
The water labs,
this is a non threshold substance.
So all water requires them to say,
to report back to water,
positive or negative.
They're not required to quantify.
However,
these water labs have also realized
there's an issue when you're getting
under Pika grams.
So what they're doing is going back
after reporting the positive,
hey,
let's see if we can estimate with this
level is it's an inexact science at Pika
gram quantities in my understanding,
um,
to,
you know,
estimate what those levels are.
Okay.
You can see some variations.
So Nevada is unwilling to sanction the
fight based on all this information.
So they get,
they get the initial notice that we got.
Also,
I think it was December six saying,
look,
there was an issue in,
in August,
these longterm metabolites reappeared
again.
But we've since had four negative tests.
We don't believe that the August,
you know,
reappearance is a re administration.
There's no sanction here.
Nevada,
you don't even have jurisdiction over
the August tests.
Again,
keep in mind,
these are UFC tests.
Nevada doesn't mandate it,
but Nevada says,
look closer to a fight.
We do take jurisdiction.
We will adopt these Usada tests.
So you saw it.
It didn't need to,
to,
to notify.
They thought out of an abundance of
caution,
let's let Nevada know that this issue
exists.
God Damn saw what the fuck they said,
hey wait,
that's,
that's all good.
And you saw it,
good,
bad.
It gets this.
I talk with them.
They're like,
Whoa,
this is,
this is concerning.
But we don't see anything within our
jurisdiction here.
So I certainly hope that no subsequent
tests show up positive because that
could be an issue.
And sure enough,
you sought it collects a sample from
John on 12,
nine.
They expedited the results cause they
knew a fight was coming up and they do
that now when fights or close or the
collections are done close to a fight,
and here,
you know,
he pulses back up to,
uh,
you know,
between 60 and 80 pika grams.
So Nevada gets this,
uh,
this was last week,
man,
the days of run together for me.
So,
uh,
a week ago,
Friday we have in,
uh,
Bob Bennett who's the executive
director.
While I'm a big fan of these great guys
out in Nevada,
but I remember FBI agent,
so we got it done around.
He is.
He's one of the reasons why it probably
wasn't sanctioned in Nevada was because
they're so by the book I get angry
because I wanted to fight to be in
Nevada.
But I understand Bob's position.
Yep.
Implicitly.
So.
So let me make clear what happened.
Bob came in,
Anthony Martin Marinell,
the chairman of the commission came in
and a couple representatives from the
Nevada attorney general's office.
So they are the ones that prosecute
cases involving ped,
you said violates Nevada regs.
So we share all this with them and lists
like you did with me.
Correct.
Share it all with them.
And look,
there's some misconception out there.
They did not say this fight.
Absolutely not happening next week.
In fact,
they,
I think we're understanding these
issues,
but said,
look,
you know,
optically this doesn't look great and we
feel that out of an abundance of caution
that we need to have a public hearing
and be very transparent about this cause
this is,
this is some weird shit.
Um,
this was last Friday.
So we're eight days out from the fight.
So,
you know,
we start talking about,
hey,
when can we potentially have this?
And unfortunately,
Christmas holiday,
several of the commissioners weren't
even in town.
And basically what they said is,
look,
we will absolutely do this if you want
us to,
but likely that hearing would not be
until today,
Thursday or maybe tomorrow,
Friday.
And you know,
Marinello is like,
look,
I,
I'm starting to get my head around this,
but I can't guarantee you that my other
commissioners or me are going to come
out the same way.
So you're taking,
you know,
you're taking a chance here that,
that we could say,
well,
we need more information.
So,
so basically they were willing to listen
to it.
Um,
I think they were starting to wrap their
heads around it,
but didn't feel that they were up to
speed enough on it.
They didn't have the luxury that Andy
Foster and California have.
Remember when John tested positive in
July,
2018 that fight was in California
because that fight was in California,
California retained jurisdiction.
They've had two very public hearings on
John when they suspended his license.
And most recently,
a week and a half ago when they
reinstated his license.
So Andy and the commission,
we're very familiar with the world
termina ball.
They were very familiar with the
longterm metabolite.
And in fact Andy was somewhat critical
of Usada during the last hearing.
He thought after looking at all the
details after reading,
you know,
Mclaren's a position that there was no
evidence that this was done on purpose.
He thought,
man,
maybe they went a little bit hard on
him.
And he stated that in that,
in that second hearing.
So with the reemergence of the Pika gram
quantity of this m three longterm
metabolite Andy in the commission,
unlike Nevada,
didn't need to get up to speed on it.
They've already had two public hearings
on John's issue.
They were intimately familiar with,
you know,
some of these dynamics of this drug and
the metabolites and,
and that's why he felt comfortable based
on their familiarization with it.
And based on these written absolute
statements by these experts.
So there was no ray ingestion one.
And then the second thing which we
haven't covered is these experts said,
based on these low level Pika grams,
there's no performance enhancing
benefit.
And that's an important point because if
you would have told you fc look,
this is still remnants from a year and a
half ago,
but we can't rule out that he's not
getting a performance enhancing benefit
from it.
Well in that instance,
I'll tell you,
and you know I,
I stand by this,
I w I would leave this company if
somebody told me otherwise,
if there was any indication that there
would be a benefit from him,
even though it technically wasn't a
violation,
I'm not going to stand by while anybody
licenses that guy to fight.
Could it been,
could this have been somehow or another
mitigated by communicating these results
to Nevada earlier?
Well,
we didn't announce the fight.
The John was going to fight and in
Nevada and tell October,
but in October,
so you have said,
hey look,
here's this issue.
Sure.
Potentially buy.
But the issue was you saw to hadn't come
to that.
They were in the middle of that point of
consulting with other professional
sports leagues with the other water
labs.
They hadn't reached their conclusion.
Their science expert hadn't determined,
Hey,
this is definitely residual,
no performance dancing.
They were still going through that data
at that point.
So what they've told me is,
look,
we,
we tried to hurry that along as fast as
possible.
We wanted to make sure that,
that,
you know,
we went through this and very,
very detailed and no stone left
unturned.
When,
when did they reach this conclusion
does,
so this was early December,
so December six that letter went out
saying we've had these two low level
positives back in August.
Okay.
But here we are.
I mean,
this is the end of December.
What could this have been headed off at
the pass?
Well,
again,
when Nevada first got notified,
they thought like,
we were hoping,
well,
he's had four negative tests,
so he's probably going to be negative
going forward here.
Right?
I mean,
that's what,
you know,
the lay person would think,
okay,
he's probably out of the woods now.
But you know,
again,
getting back to what period of time is
this and John's preparation and if you
look at some of these numbers and when
these metabolites appear and disappear
in early August,
John was preparing his defense for this
arbitration.
I think he had an idea based on talking
to his attorneys like,
Hey,
we've got a pretty good shot here of
some mitigating factors where this is
potentially going to get reduced.
So I think,
you know,
he starts to get a little bit motivated,
gets in the gym,
start training again clearly in early
December.
That's a period of time when our
fighters that close to a fight are
bringing down that body weight right
there,
cutting body fat,
they're losing,
you know,
a little bit of water.
So it certainly seems to correlate
these,
these pulsing,
you know,
affects with when is just theoretical,
right?
That it's released from adipose tissue.
Absolutely.
It is.
So,
uh,
this positive result was announced when,
so a week ago yesterday as you saw it as
announced,
you saw,
it notifies us the UFC.
That always happens and they notify if
any commission has jurisdiction.
At this point,
this close to a fight.
Nevada has jurisdiction.
So I get the call and you can imagine
what's going through my head.
I mean I,
I've gotten so many of these calls now.
I literally for the first five or 10
minutes,
can bury my head in my hand and think
through exactly how this thing's going
to play out and you know,
it's going to be,
hey,
Nevada is going to say,
wait a second.
What's going on here?
We need to root this out.
John's going to say,
Jesus Christ,
like,
what is going on in my life?
I can't get a fucking break.
I'm trying to be careful.
I even went through with DC.
DC's going to react and he reacts.
He's going to be,
I fucking told you this was the case.
This guy's a cheater.
You know,
you saw it as bullshit.
Novitsky is bullshit.
All this stuff goes through my head and
the first five or 10 minutes,
what's,
how's Dana gonna React?
How's hundred are going to react when I
have to go over to his office and
explain this out to them?
It played out exactly as I saw it.
It's,
it's,
it's some of the worst days of my career
when I get these calls.
Um,
but you know,
every bone was notified in Nevada was in
our office two days later.
And again,
I mean there's been some criticism of
them out there.
Um,
I don't fault them.
This is a complicated issue that
optically doesn't look great and to do
anything in a rush manner would be
difficult.
They did everything they could to afford
us.
Having a hearing problem was,
it was just,
it was too close to,
to a fight essentially to get this out,
this issue with optics,
right?
Cause if you go on twitter,
everybody's calling him a cheat.
Everybody's saying that you know,
anybody that sanctions this is you're
sanctioning cheating for someone to get
an understanding of what this is like.
It actually requires probably more than
we've done now over the last hour and 15
minutes.
Yeah.
And I appreciate this forum.
I mean,
Dana and I went on sports center and
announced it in three minute hit and I
came out of there going,
absolutely everyone in the world is
going to say this is bullshit.
You can't,
this is what,
we're going to have a hard time doing
this in two hours here,
Mrs Things.
Yeah,
you've got,
you've got to delve into it and you've
also have to put your trust and reliance
on these experts.
They have a education professional
career of 20 to 25 years to come up with
these absolutes.
There's no one else in the world,
but maybe a dozen people that can come
up with these conclusions.
You do have to put your,
you know,
your faith and in their background and
their careers and their knowledge and
education and you know,
a red which those absolutes were,
that there was no evidence of any read
ingestion.
This is by multiple,
um,
experts and that John would not have
retained any performance benefit based
on these low level Pika gram amounts.
Well,
I'm happy that we were going to have
this out there.
So people,
if they have the time,
if they're really that interested in it,
this is probably a more in depth
discussion of this,
then you're going to get anywhere else.
But I really wish we could have gotten
something like this to Nevada and Nevada
could have gone over this and looked at
what,
what I'm saying,
what you're saying.
It seems to me that we could have just
had some sort of a meeting and kept this
fight in Nevada and it would have saved
everybody a lot of heartache.
Yeah,
I mean I think things were pointing in
that,
but there was no guarantees on that nice
baby.
It's still come on.
It's Vegas.
You know,
the other thing that was being looked at
was,
was fairness to these athletes.
Really you're going to put,
you're going to put John and gus,
maybe more importantly in a position
where he doesn't know until two days or
a day before whether this fight is
happening or not.
I mean these and not even mentioning the
other fighters on the card.
And Look,
you can talk to,
and I have to Sean and Mick and Dana and
hunter.
All these fighters want to be on the big
paper views.
They know the bigger the fight at the
top of the card,
the more eyes are on that fight.
And when you have a spectacular fight in
the first second fight on the card,
if it's on a big paper view with a giant
fight at the top of it that can propel
your career,
your next fight,
you could be fighting the main event on
fight pass and progressed from there.
So I think,
you know,
I think it's accurate to say that
generally everybody wants these,
these cards to be as big as possible.
And when all the experts are telling us
100% this isn't a sanction b,
he's not retaining any performance
enhancing benefits.
I think,
and clearly Dane and hunter thought
this,
we have an obligation to do what we can
do for fairness for John.
Definitely for gus for the rest of the
card to try to make this fight happen
going forward.
Is there any way we could ever prevent
something like this from happening again
with the similar situation in place like
Nevada?
So here's,
I think we have a couple solutions to
that and it's not necessarily relative
to the commission,
but one thing that obviously protected
John a lot,
and this was the frequency of testing,
you know,
if you look at his numbers and these
were,
these were instances where they
collected samples,
but in many of these cases they did
multiple tests on him.
And that means,
you know,
the tests I'm reading were for the
anabolic steroid panel.
But in addition to that,
they may have done a biological passport
test on that same collection the May
have done in hgh test and epo test.
And this is all confidential that you
sought.
It doesn't release all this information
to these numbers on the publicly
available website that you don't see
what those tests are done.
So the reality,
and they just told me this is John was
one of the most,
if not the most tested athlete over
these last six months.
When you look at total amount of tests
on his samples,
excuse me,
one thing that obviously protecting them
here was that volume of testing and so
you saw it,
it came to us and said,
hey,
we think that you probably should,
you know,
up the amount of tests that you're
doing.
So,
um,
we just renewed a contract with Usada
and were reduce.
We're increasing our testing numbers by
30 to 40%.
We currently,
uh,
the first three years of the program
went under contract for approximately
2,700
tests and starting this next year we're
going to up that to around 43 4,400
tests.
So I think there is going to be more of
a burden they're going to be,
you know,
you saw to showing up in more doorsteps
early in the morning of more of our
athletes.
But I think this is a perfect example
that that increased volume of testing
actually can be a protectant to the
athlete,
especially when you're talking in these
low level Pika gram quantities and
contaminated cases and things like that.
We just got to get athletes to stop
taking any supplement.
That's not third party tested great
points.
So here's what we've done in that area.
So about three months ago you sought a
hosted a working group and included the
UFC.
Myself and our worst nutritionist,
Clinton Wattenberg who you've met were
there majorly baseball was there,
the Department of Defense was there.
There's been war fighters who have
purchased supplements at bases over in
Iraq and Afghanistan that contain a
federal and another bad products.
Some of them potentially have died as a
result of ingesting them.
So they definitely have an interest in
safety and dietary supplements.
And you saw it as experts were there.
What we did is we invited in the major
third party certification companies and
each one took a half day presenting what
their programs look like.
We went back and huddled after each one
and huddled at the conclusion and said,
what is a platinum standard third party
certification look like?
Let's all these presentations we got,
what was strengths and one's weaknesses
and the others and we have to put a
perfect one together.
What was it?
What does it look like over the last
month we've been offering,
um,
a paper that's going to be published in
a scientific journal going over with
that gold standard platinum standard
looks like,
um,
going forward any third party
certification company that can meet that
and there's some that are very close.
I think we'll be able to do it very
quickly.
We are going to say,
you saw it is going to say this is an
approved line of supplements.
We approve you to take this and this
something that we've been unable to do
in the first three and a half years of
the program.
And I'll tell you joe,
it's the most common question I get from
our athletes.
What's you sought approved?
And as soon as I say you saw,
doesn't approve any supplements,
but here's how you ensure your safety.
They stop listening,
goes in one ear out the other.
This is a silly suggestion,
but why doesn't the UFC come up with its
own supplement and provide them to the
fighters and say,
you can't take anything else.
Yeah,
I mean it's definitely been talking
through sponsorships with other
supplement line.
Exactly.
There's a lot of dynamics to it.
It's not as easy as doing it overnight
and it's distribution method.
Just see if he could say,
hey,
you can take creatine,
you could take,
you know,
all the multivitamins,
you could take,
you know,
a branch chain amino acids and all these
things that have been proven to be
effective.
But that's,
that's weird too.
Right?
It's like they're effective.
Meaning they enhance performance and
recovery,
but they don't do enough to be
considered a performance enhancing drug.
Yeah.
And they're present in the food supply.
So like basically out of community,
you can go eat 10 chicken breasts or you
know,
have us a couple scoops of protein if
you're on the go and don't have time to
do it.
So I think,
again,
apples and oranges in terms of
performance enhancing or not.
Um,
so the theory would be we have an
approved when,
when I'm or dawn or ask that question,
what's approved,
I can say,
here's,
let's say NSF NSF has 1200 supplements
that are approved.
I'd say all 1200 of these are approved.
You should only use these.
If something were to happen to an
athlete,
they'd used and approved line of
supplements to get out of jail free
card.
If they can prove it and you saw it
independently prove it,
there's no sanction.
I think that is going to go a long way
and I'll give you a reason for that.
Majorly baseball does that.
They have for the last couple of years
now they have some advantage and that
all their athletes are employees and are
coming in to the same facility for
during the season,
so they have some control over there as
well.
We don't,
our athletes are spread amongst,
I think 46 countries throughout the
world,
so it's more of a challenge.
But baseball said the only supplements
we're allowing in the clubhouse or in a
facility are,
and they use NSF supplements.
They had zero contaminated supplement
cases last year.
They had,
I think they're testing numbers were
four times the amount of our testing
numbers and zero contaminated
supplements.
I mean the proof's in the pudding right
there,
so they have to deal with NSF.
I don't know if it's a deal other than
they've examined who those certification
companies are and they feel that
they're,
you know,
at the top of the line,
we don't want to exclude any and that's
why we're contributing to this paper to
say,
look,
anyone could be one of these approved
lines,
but you must meet this criteria for
platinum standard program,
but it's coming from someone who was in
his supplement business.
Me,
that's the wild west out there.
Boy Is,
I mean there's a,
there's a lot of shit out there that's
just,
they purposely add performance enhancing
drugs to their stuff because it's cheap
and people take it and they experience
these gains and then they sell a lot of
it and then you get a following.
Exactly.
I saw that when I was with the FDA there
is,
and what they normally will do for maybe
the first six months of the product,
they'll spike it with something if
they're going that route and then to
decrease liability thereafter.
They've already got the following.
The bad stuff's working like,
like hell.
And then they back off just in the
government and people go,
oh,
my body must have adapted.
Exactly.
Choose Sun.
This.
It's really such a shame because this is
such a fantastic fight.
I mean,
there's so much drama involved already.
Just having John Jones returning,
having Alexander Gustafson looking
absolutely sensational in his last fight
with glover to sharer all the trash talk
and hype and intensity in the fact that
this is really other than DC versus
John.
This is the fight that people want to
see in the light heavyweight division.
And look,
nobody is saying,
and I'm certainly not saying that John
didn't do anything wrong,
he obviously did.
John has two times now tested positive
for prohibited substance says.
However,
in both occasions,
arbitrators have determine that it was
not done intentionally.
So anyone who says it all,
John's getting off light on this,
he's been suspended for almost two and a
half years,
for lack with a lack of evidence of any
intentional use are cheating.
You know how much money he's probably
lost in those two and a half years?
How many tens of millions of dollars
doesn't reputation anybody who says that
he got off Scot free on this.
I would argue the otherwise he was
felled to the strictest of liability
standards out there.
Some of the top of their game money
earning potential like him.
This is also an incredible amount of
stress and,
and absolutely it's on him.
He feels and he hears what people are
saying about them and that's,
that's got to be very difficult also
again coming off of this massive
suspension.
So he's coming off of the suspension,
which was huge bay,
very public,
very worldwide,
right after the cocaine,
the car accident,
the,
the previous,
the Dick Pills that had the,
the stuff.
And I mean this is so many things.
And then to have this happen literally
the week of and have the fight moved to
California.
I mean,
and I get the skepticism that's out
there again,
without delving into this,
I've spent hours and hours and these
experts have spent their careers looking
into that.
That's really what's required to get a
comprehension and understanding of it.
Um,
another thing,
another argument,
John's being treated specially because
he's John,
but we had another athlete that this
somewhat identical thing happened too,
but nowhere near at the level of John.
So a kid by the name of grant Dawson.
So Grant Dawson last summer was in the
date and white contender series had an
awesome fight.
Dana's like you got a contract kid,
uh,
we get them into the Usada program
there.
Would you solder quote program requires
you to disclose everything you've used
going back 12 months or one year.
The idea being,
look,
even though you weren't under the
program,
if you used,
you know,
oral Terenna ball eight or nine months
ago,
there could still be an advantage that
you beginning,
you know,
we're not going to necessarily suspend
you because you weren't subject to the
program then,
but we're not going to let you fight or
right away you can have to be in the
program for a certain amount of time
testing clean.
So he didn't,
he didn't disclose it.
He was using anything.
His first test,
he tests positive for m three metabolite
low levels.
He goes to arbitration,
argues,
testifies under oath.
I've never heard of this substance.
I've never taken it.
I would never cheat.
Here are all the Suttons I was using.
I can't find it.
The arbitrator,
heres the hearing you saw to goes to
them and says,
hold on a second,
we're looking into this matter.
Talking to baseball,
whatever you saw it,
it comes out that hey,
we can't prove that this didn't enter
his substance a year before that
disclosure required him to disclose what
he was using.
So he was basically led off and an
eligible,
so John's not the only person in the UFC
that this has happened to,
not,
not withstanding other professional
sports leagues,
other Olympics,
it's happened to other athletes.
He's not the only one.
So I think what's important for people,
I get the skepticism,
but I think it's very important that
people don't accuse someone of something
that they didn't do.
And I want you,
if you're listening to this,
I want you to imagine if you're John
Jones and you trying to get your shit
together and you didn't do anything new,
he didn't do anything different.
We've got to have a path of redemption
for people.
You got,
you have to,
and if John,
as you're saying,
and all these tests conclude,
if he didn't do anything,
folks,
you got to stop saying he's cheating.
You get you got,
he's not cheating if he's not cheating.
And if it's showing that these are these
longterm residual metabolites that are
an incredibly small dosage,
it's,
there's a real cheaters out there and
John's fucked up.
He has fucked up and you were all right
to be upset at him when he fucked up.
This is not as Lisa's my conclusion
after talking to you and,
and,
and I've,
I've talked to some independent
scientists that were skeptical about
some of the aspects of it,
but they're also,
they're skeptical because they're not up
to date perhaps on the differences in
this,
this pulsing effect or the fact that
this is something that is relatively,
there's not a lot of,
a lot of documentation on this mean this
is,
this is something that's relatively new
in terms of our ability to understand
Pika grams.
Our ability to understand this pulsing
affect all these different v these
variables that you have to take into
account when it comes to this.
People love to call cheat,
they love to and it's good.
It's good that the people were out there
keeping people honest.
But I think you got to,
we got to look at this the right way and
I think the right way is what you're,
the way you're laying it out here.
I don't see any holes.
So you know,
a couple things in the future that
people can look forward to.
Look,
we want,
and John was to fight in Nevada again
and Nevada has basically said,
look,
I think we understand this his shoe,
but we need to have this hearing.
There will be a public hearing on this.
My understanding is early quarter one,
so look,
you know,
don't take word for it.
Wait until
January.
I'm sure they'll call some of these
experts to testify,
introduced some of these documents to
the public record longer even than this
conversation.
Yes.
My,
that would be my guess.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean that's,
that's to come,
the whole thing is such a disaster for
everybody else on the card for Amanda
Nunez and Cris Cyborg and for all the
people on the undercard.
I mean it's just to have them to move
all the way to California when I'm happy
about though is that the fight is still
happening.
I'm very happy the fight is still
I am,
and again,
I have to take an objective look about
is this fair as it relates to how our
policy and what the rules are.
And you know,
when you have,
you know,
one of the experts in the world,
Dr.
Daniel Wagner of this myrtle laboratory
issue,
an absolute statement like there is no
evidence the Dh cmt has been
readministered and that based on these
low levels,
he does not retaining a performance
enhancing benefit.
How out of fairness and implementing the
program do you prevent this fight from
happening?
You can't do that.
It would be categorically unfair.
Um,
moving forward from here,
what changes and what do we do to stop
something like this from happening?
Well,
again,
I think the increased volume of testing
is going to help.
I think being able to specifically
direct our athletes to approve line of
supplements will help.
Um,
but you know,
hey,
we can dawn and I can message the hell
out of these things.
But you know,
it,
it takes the athletes and their camps to
listen to what we're saying.
So I mean if anything good comes out of
this,
hopefully it's a warning to those other
hours,
others out there about hair,
how careful you need to be.
So to,
just to wrap this up so people
understand if you,
if you want to put a button on this,
there's no evidence whatsoever of any
microdosing.
So this is one of the concerns people
were worried about microdosing no
evidence whatsoever of microdosing
wouldn't be a substance.
You were generally microdose you do the
endogenous substances,
not exotic genus is also no evidence of
the short term and medium term.
Medium.
A medium term.
Yup.
Metabolites that were recognized by her
chank off.
Does that any say his name again?
I think it is.
Why don't I Gregory Gregory.
It's not even Gregory [inaudible] that's
the only test we have no parent compound
ever found as well.
These are these the only tests we have
that show these longterm short term and
medium term metabolites.
These,
the short term in the medium term ones
that would be indicative of him taking
it recently don't exist at any point in
time during these tests.
Correct.
So this is most likely something that is
inside of his body that is an incredibly
small levels.
And is it safe to say that the detection
levels,
that the detection methods are far
superior today than they were a year
ago,
two years ago,
three years ago,
increase by thousands of percentage
points in sensitivity?
I mean again,
and how recently over the last five
years and how recently have they,
if they improve from today versus a year
ago?
Yeah,
I believe so.
Again,
you know,
when I heard about the one pika gram
detection of the m three metabolite,
you know,
that was something that happened this
year.
I'm not aware of that ever being that
low of a number in any time in the past.
So I think,
you know,
literally week by week,
month by one month as we're going here,
that level of sensitivity is increasing
and off essentially no possible
performance enhancing benefits from
these incredibly low levels.
That's what the experts are telling me.
Look,
and again,
I'm,
I'm not the expert.
I don't want to profess that I am,
but what,
what do I have to go to?
I need to go to those experts that have
made careers out of studying these
substances and the benefits.
And they were all universally telling me
that there's no performance enhancing
benefit,
full compliance by Jon Jones in terms of
being there for Usada at every single
task.
Uh,
notifying his whereabouts,
doing everything by the book.
In terms of what the UFC requires and
what you saw to require.
Yeah,
so our program has a three strike
policy.
So basically,
you know,
if you miss a test for an unexplained
reason three times,
then it could be a violation.
John's never had one whereabouts strike.
He's always been available when you saw
it as tried to test them.
And again,
especially recency.
Recently one of the most tested athletes
in the UFC.
Wasn't there one test in the past where
you sought a showed up at the gym and
there was some sort of speculation that
John was hiding under the ring pre Usada
that that was pre Usada before I got
here.
I've,
I've heard about that at all.
The details.
I don't know whether it's true or not.
I think it was a Nevada state athletic
commission test.
My recollection's.
Right.
But it wasn't,
he sought a test.
Okay.
So there's no reason in terms of how
you're looking at this particular case
that this fight should not take place or
that John should be sanctioned to any
further.
There isn't and look,
it's,
it's the least compelling argument,
but I think you know,
you have to look at it.
You have to look at the common sense
approach to this.
A guy who went through a year and a half
almost suspension to vary,
I would categorize as embarrassing
public hearings in California along
arbitration hearing before Mclaren.
All this science is rooted out about how
long this stuff stays in your system.
Longterm metabolites for months,
maybe years you're going to choose to
use oral Terenna ball still after going
through all of that leading up to a
fight.
I don't buy that.
See,
I don't think,
I think I agree with what you're saying,
but in terms of people fucking up,
there are no bounds on human stupidity
and in terms of people's ability to do
impulsive things that are irrational,
that wind up sabotaging their career is
almost more of an indication that people
are willing to do than not.
There's,
it's very,
it's low,
you're less likely.
And this is in terms of,
especially in particular [inaudible]
fighters,
fighters are ridiculously impulsive.
It's one of the things that categorizes
and it's a characteristic of the,
the type of human being that gets
involved in that line of work in the
first place.
They're wild motherfuckers.
They're crazy.
They do crazy shit.
And I just,
I don't,
I don't buy that.
That would be new level crazy.
And look again,
I categorize as a new level,
crazy guy,
least compelling argument.
I agree.
At least compelling,
but I think we'd be remiss if we didn't
at least consider that.
Uh,
I,
okay,
I see your point.
I don't buy it that,
that,
that part I don't buy.
I buy all the science and I'm a big John
Jones Fan.
I mean,
you can call me a John Jones suck up all
day long.
I think he's one of the greatest of all
time and I think it's not over for him.
I think he still could reach,
I don't even think he's at his peak.
I think he's still got time to be the
greatest of all time.
If he hasn't already achieved that.
But I think that he's also,
he's a wild man.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why he's so
great.
It's one of the reasons why you opened
up the fight with Shogun at 22 years old
with a flying knee.
And he's a wild motherfucker.
That's who he is.
And it's one of many reasons besides his
talent that he's so God damn good.
I know the lows of the lows.
He's gone through these last two years.
You really can't leave how low those
lines.
And so again,
look,
I don't disagree with you that that's
not out of the area of consideration,
but man,
I,
I just don't,
I don't get anybody.
It could be by reckless.
I hope you're right.
Um,
I also worry that fighters often in
times,
and I'm not accusing John of doing this,
but oftentimes surround themselves with
morons and these morons give them poor
advice.
And these morons think that they have
ways to skirt systems and get around the
rules and they have people that,
you know,
throw a bunch of fancy words their way
and they want to believe.
And this happens all the time.
This happens all the time with fighters
in regards to financial management and
advice that they get with that.
Uh,
I mean I've seen like world class
fighters do ridiculous shit in terms of
strength and conditioning because some
asshole with a good vocabulary talks him
into some nonsense.
This is just one of the things that
happens with fighters and oftentimes
they can be around someone who gives him
poor advice in terms of what they can
and cannot get away with when it comes
to supplementation and when it comes to
steroid use.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I see that that all over the place.
In John's case,
however,
to give credit where credit's due,
you know,
his team after the initial positive with
a dick pills was very interactive with
me and Donna and you know,
checking supplements,
Hey,
what line should we go to show they,
you know,
to give them credit.
They definitely showed a increase
exercise of care when it came to
supplementation with John.
Well,
that's great to hear.
And I really hope this is a thing of the
past,
and I hope this is the last time we ever
have to talk about John in this term and
that moving forward,
we just talk about in terms of his
performances
and his,
his fights,
and you know,
what he's already achieved.
So any youngest UFC champion of all
time,
uh,
anything else?
Yeah,
so I was going to bring this up at the
beginning,
but the golden snitch,
that's Presevo,
that's Brendan Shop's name.
He gave it to you.
So taking on a life of its own,
and I think,
I think you know the last time we talked
about Donna asking Alexa,
who,
let me see,
we'll see what Siri says.
Hold on a sec.
Let's see what Siri says.
Well,
I've never tried this.
Hold on a second.
Who is the Golden Snitch?
He's some inflammation.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
Quite niche.
It's something in Harry Potter,
which I did last time on.
And I mentioned it was in,
I think,
my wikipedia profile.
It had me as Aka the golden snitch.
Hey Siri,
who is the golden snitch?
Wow.
Siri.
Siri keeps going with quad itch.
So someone took it down from yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I do that.
Well I think we talked about,
you're like,
Eh,
I dunno.
They just did it.
Um,
so I think I told you about us backup
already.
Coworkers call me.
Yes.
My family calls me.
They call you.
The goldens friends called me.
I was at the MMA awards last year and
some Yahoo had a few pops back in me is
screaming in between presentations,
the golden snitches.
I'm slinking down in my chair,
my girlfriend and I,
we got damn the golden stitch.
It's backup already popped up.
Beautiful.
Just fucking when they do that,
just put your hands up in the air shake
q one.
So you know,
definitely should make a shirt during
shows.
All sit pretty close to the cage.
Go out in between a fight into the
bathroom and it's not Joe Rogan level
half the damn arena standing up.
Excited to see you walking in and out of
the fight or walk.
But two or three people in that walk
when I go backstage to check on each
side of the golden snitch.
And so give them wreck.
You know Steve Reed,
you know,
so you've read our bald security,
that bad ass looking guy on stage.
He'll come back stage just mate,
they're calling me the snitch out there,
man.
I think I'm you.
That poor God pays for it.
Um,
we were in a scary guy,
dude.
He's a great dude.
That guy is at the top of his game.
Insecurity.
Just background is unbelievable.
I saw him one time in Las Vegas during a
fight.
He was sitting on the floor.
Something's happened in the fight.
The crowd goes fucking bananas and
everybody stands up on the floor.
Steve stands up and just motions sit
down and the entire fucking section sat
down.
200 plus people.
I'm like,
dude,
if you can,
without even having to touch somebody,
just stand up by your presence alone and
control something like that.
I mean,
the best I've ever seen,
he's legit as it gets.
So are you going to do anything to
market this?
Well,
that's getting to my story.
It's not marketing,
but let me finish the story here.
So I'm in Chicago this year.
I think there was a paper review.
You were there,
right?
Yes.
So something happened and I was late
getting to the arena and they had cut
off kind of the loading dock.
I couldn't get to it.
So I had my oldest daughter with me.
And so we're having to walk through
where all the crowds walking in and you
know,
dudes,
all of Golden Snitch,
hey,
can we get a picture golden snitch?
My daughter's like,
what the fuck is going on?
How old is your daughter?
So she's 22 so two days ago,
Christmas morning,
I'm opening up presence.
So I get the presidents from my
daughters,
the three of them,
and my middle daughter's very artistic.
And so they create these cool sculpted
beer mugs and there's four of them.
One of them's like Bald Guy Brewing
Novitsky something and one of them says
golden snitch brewing company.
So it's cool looking thing.
And she,
she drew me a black and white kind of
rendition of all four,
which I'm gonna hang up really cool.
So then my girlfriend's there.
So she hands me the box and she's been
telling me all along,
she goes,
I got you the best fucking present ever
in the history of presence.
I'm like,
the hell is this?
So I open up the box.
Oh my gosh,
she's got this series of tee shirts and
I think,
what size are you?
Large.
There we go.
Nancy,
you,
since you created it,
you literally and figuratively have to
wear it.
Now this is outrageous.
So that picture,
there's some,
oh,
say who you go baby ladies and
gentlemen,
circle close.
Look at that.
So I posted a boot on this or something.
Man That's pretty sure can came from
Moscow.
I think I can say this.
Hopefully they'll let me back in,
but it's out in front of KGB or FSP
headquarters to that building in the
background is kgb.
F has now known as FSB.
Oh Wow.
So yeah.
So I posted a picture of,
she got me like 20 shirts.
I put them on,
not private instagram,
facebook,
everybody in the world's like,
take my money man.
Where can I get one wearing wearing the
weigh ins tomorrow.
Alright,
you guys created it.
You've got to own it now.
I got one for shop too that you can feel
that on the shops mad at you.
Is He?
Yeah,
he's,
he called you the golden wrap now I'll
change.
I thought maybe you got him in here.
He's informed.
Misinformed.
He thinks first of all that you were an
employee of you saw it.
Oh,
there you go.
And that now you're an employee of the
UFC.
Uh,
he's misinformed about that and I think
he,
he likes to call skeptical.
He skeptical hippo.
I am skeptical as well,
but I,
one thing that I've learned from doing
this podcast over the years is that
there's no fucking way there's,
it's an,
it's impossible to know everything.
It is impossible
and you have to rely on the expertise of
the people who have spent a lifetime
studying these things.
It's very important.
Here's another thing.
There's no way these people could be
lying about this and it wouldn't
massively damaged their career going
forward.
It'd be done.
Someone would find out,
someone would get to them,
the other scientists without them.
There would be studies done,
there would be papers done,
the Internet would find out about it.
Everybody would know.
There's no way it's,
it's pretty unprecedented in writing
with the lack of these studies.
They were Chenko one being the my
sanding even right.
How'd he say it?
The check.
Yeah.
It's pretty unprecedented that they
would put these absolutes in writing.
Um,
you know,
with his law,
I think they looked at it very hard and
detailed and obviously they weren't
quick and turning it around.
And we would have loved this decision to
be made a lot earlier so we could have
rooted and vetted it out with Nevada.
But they did indeed sign their names to
these pretty absolute statements and
what,
what else can the UFC and I do,
um,
when these experts are putting those
absolutes out there and I get the people
go,
oh,
whoops,
could you actually do,
you got to understand folks,
this would be career suicide.
This is,
this is the,
this is cutting edge science we're
talking about.
There's too many people that would have
a vested interest in calling bullshit.
It's,
it's not something they don't fuck
around when it comes to these things
that people that are at the,
the front of the line,
when it comes to catching people on
these things and the science that
they're important,
they're,
they're involved with.
It's,
this is not,
you get,
you can't like gas on the outside with
no education.
It's just not wise.
And this is what I keep seeing over and
over again is people that have some
knowledge,
a little bit of knowledge,
and they're,
they're pretending that they are,
they have a phd in this shit
go.
I mean,
for those that want to,
you know,
do more detective work,
go read Mclaren's written decision on
John's July,
2018 July,
2018 tests.
Go read the rich hank off study on the
DH CMT and the metabolites and go read
the recent clomiphene.
Um,
study where it shows is chlorinated
substance.
It's pulsing,
it goes away,
comes back higher than before.
It goes away,
comes back,
lower,
goes away,
comes back higher.
Crazy stuff.
Okay.
Um,
we good when,
when can someone get one of these?
She only made about 15 of them for me,
man.
You got to sell these.
You have to sell these.
Maybe do something for,
maybe do something for charity or
something.
Jamie.
Dot.
Yeah.
Someone needs to stop.
We can talk,
but then it's not exclusive.
You want to have the exclusive shirt
when nobody else can get on line and not
into that man.
All right,
Jeff.
Thank you very much.
The clarifying please folks,
please have an open mind.
Please.
I know you want to call it bullshit.
There's times there's times call
bullshit,
but there's times
to recognize that this is a complicated
issue and that we've laid it out as I'm,
I'm pretty convinced.
Appreciate it Joe.
And I'm dumb,
so you might be smarter than me.
All.
Bye everybody.
Yeah.